being bombed relentlessly where with a
convoy taking an aid and hoping to reach
those still there
this is the last route in or out and it
has to be done fast across an open
Farmers field where every vehicle can be
a Target
the city surrounded on three sides by
Russian troops at this point and there's
a stream of cars ferrying the civilians
out of the combat zone
the window to get across the last
remaining pedestrian bridge across the
desna river is rapidly closing but the
Russians have spotted this Escape Route
and minutes after we arrive they hit it
come on
okay the shelling is very close
get it from here
I don't I don't
okay don't worry don't worry there's a
mad scramble to get out as the attacks
keep on coming all right go go go now
let's go the Russians have used this
tactic repeatedly in this war 100 meters
away
lines of civilians lay on the ground as
the shelling goes on
K themselves up to walk through these
bombings they've no option only chance
and a prayer will get them through this
there are scores of people trying to
flee with bags on their backs they're
guided through the fields by soldiers
whose guns are no match for this heavy
artillery
they've been living without heating food
water or electricity for weeks everyone
come and go from the space the Russians
have cut off chernoheve now and
destroyed the only Corridor out and
they're targeting those trying to escape
their bombs and Rockets
inside chernoheve the mayor has managed
to film some of the destruction there
are bombed houses and buildings on fire
everywhere
there are still an estimated 150 000
people trapped inside this city it's
strategically important because it
stands right across the northern route
chosen by Russia for its Advance on the
capital
we cannot cope with all the dead the
mayor says it's Carnage
we take refuge in a gym in a basement
with a group of volunteer soldiers
everyone who has made it out of Journey
has withdrawn to nearby Villages
themselves coming under bombardment
this gives the volunteer soldiers time
to make phone calls home one month on
fighting this war their families and
children are mostly well away from the
chaos and death they're seeing here on a
daily basis
my heart is just breaking one father
tells us it's very difficult because I'm
so used to being with my family they're
my whole life away from their own
families they're saving the lives of
others
how important is human life another says
what could be more important than the
lives of little children little girls
and boys nothing's making us do this
this is just what we have to do
Daybreak the following morning and
they're trying to work out how to get
Aid into Genevieve and the civilians out
the last route has closed and is clearly
still being targeted
paramedic asks us for help he's Yuri and
he tells us the bridge crossing point
where he was waiting to help casualties
has been shelled 15 minutes earlier
now he is wounded
he's been deafened by the blast it was
so close and he's got several shrapnel
wounds
bits have lodged in his leg and he needs
surgery there's little that can be done
on the roadside but one of our team does
what he can where from you
British
and shrapnel appears to have punctured
his lung he says he's finding it hard to
breathe targeting of civilians and
non-competence like Medics is a
potential War crime
though I went there all on my own Yuri
tells us and I saw destroyed cars
destroyed civilian cars they were all
burned out they were completely
destroyed and there was one dead
civilian with his bags
good luck yeah good luck
he leaves to try to get to a hospital
with this parting message for the world
I need
our country need your help
good luck
[Music]
nearby a farmer's field has been
littered with the remains of cluster
bomb Rockets fired from a multiple
rocket launcher we've consulted several
independent experts including the
investigative group bellingcat who've
identified them as cluster Munitions
they're being used by both sides in this
war but the angle suggest they've been
fired from Russian positions
the United Nations is investigating the
use of cluster bombs as possible war
crimes
from inside China they fear they're the
next Mario poll
they're trying to create as bigger
humanitarian disaster as possible One
China heaver official tells us because
they can't get the city militarily
they're trying to force us to give up
this way
there are constant Sirens warning of
attacks on the surrounding villages
desperate to leave no every movement
comes with risk including the buses
taking them out of here which they patch
up horribly
this was hit when it was full of
escaping women and children
Genevieve is really being hit by Tank
fire being hit by Jets he tells us some
people haven't been able to get out for
two weeks
those who've made it out talk of a
nightmarish existence
yeah
it's
held there it's hell this mother tells
us my children's godmother is still
there it's not possible to leave the
shelter there's no food no gas no
electricity it's just like Mario pull
everyone's cut off
they're distraught and terrified
used to be so beautiful she says the
rituals of death are crammed in between
the shellings as those Left Behind
struggle to live for those here this
isn't real living it's just surviving
and those trapped in chernoheve cannot
know how much longer they can hold out
Alex Crawford Sky News outside Journey
Heath